6-Mute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6-minute English from BBCLearningEnglish. I'm Neil
And I'm Beth
Every country has its own favourite foods
So when people leave home and move to a different country
Getting used to the new food there can be a surprise
Food can have strange sounding names
If you know what a toad is, it's an animal very similar to a frog
You might be surprised to hear that a famous English meal is toad in the hole
Don't worry though, it's made with sausages, not toads
In this programme we're exploring people's first impressions of a new culture through its food
We'll be hearing how two women, one a refugee, the other a dietician, adapted to the food of their new home
And as usual, we'll be learning some useful new vocabulary too
But first I have a question for you Neil
A British summer wouldn't be complete without a traditional cream tea
Skons, cream and jam eaten with a cup of tea
It sounds lovely, but strangely there have been many arguments over cream teas
So is the cream tea debate about
A, whether to drink tea or coffee
B, whether to put cream or jam onto the scone first
Or see whether strawberry or raspberry jam is better
Well, I think the controversy is whether to add cream or jam first
Okay Neil, I'll reveal the correct answer later in the programme
Natalia Techenko arrived in the Netherlands after leaving her home in Ukraine following the Russian invasion
She moved in with Veronica Grzefska, who's originally from Poland
And her family, starting them on a journey to open their own restaurants in Natalia's kitchen
Here's Natalia talking with BBC World Service programme The Food Chain
Not the... of course
At first it felt like I am well out of what they call my comfort zone
When you stay in a certain environment you get used to it
But when you move to another country where you live and work
you experience difficulties and you have to adapt to get used to local foods
Here they don't have some of the staples we had in Ukraine
Ingredients are different
And so you start working with local foods, find replacements, cook with what you have
At first Natalia felt out of her comfort zone
A familiar situation in which someone feels secure and in control
She had to adapt to her new life in the Netherlands
She had to change in order to succeed in her new situation
Some of the staple ingredients Natalia used in Ukraine weren't available in the Netherlands
A staple is a basic and important type of food that is regularly eaten by a large portion of the population
So Natalia adapted her recipes, replacing Ukrainian with Dutch ingredients
to create a new kind of cooking which her customers loved
Our second story involves Rachel Winter Roach who left her home in England
to work on the sunny island of Tobago in the southern Caribbean
Here Rachel explains some of the food challenges she faced
Sue BBC World Service Programme, the food chain
When I came out to the Caribbean I was really in for a shock when it came to
The flavoring and seasoning food and seasoning is really, really an integral part of food preparation here
Here the seasoning is multiple, multiple layers
It took me a while to get used to it because everybody has their own way of seasoning and their own little tweaks
And there are no quantities so it really takes a lot of practice, a lot of trial and error
And I think my family did not always appreciate the errors in the trials
When Rachel moved to Tobago she was in for a shock
The phrase to be in for a shock means to be sure of experiencing a surprising or unpleasant situation
In Rachel's case the surprise involved seasoning, the salt, herbs and spices added to food to enhance the flavor
In the Caribbean seasoning is a big deal
Everyone has their own seasoning recipe including little tweaks or small adjustments which they have added themselves
It took time for Rachel to develop her seasoning skills mainly through trial and error
A way of solving problems by trying a number of different methods and learning from the mistakes you make along the way
Whether you're fleeing war, starting a new job or enjoying a cream tea
It seems there's lots to learn about a place from its food including Britain
So I think it's time to reveal the answer to my question Neil
Why is the traditional British cream tea controversial?
Well I guess it was because people disagree about whether cream or jam should go on the scorn first
Which was the correct answer and anyone who says it's jam first is just wrong
Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learnt in this programme starting with comfort zone
A situation in which you feel comfortable and in control
To adapt means to change so as to successfully fit in with a new situation
A staple is a basic and important type of food that is regularly eaten by a large portion of the population
The phrase to be in for a shock means to be guaranteed to experience a surprising or unpleasant situation
A tweak is a small adjustment to something in order to improve it
And finally if you solve a problem by trial and error you try a number of different methods and learn from the mistakes you make
Once again our six minutes are up and remember to join us again next time here at six minute English
Goodbye for now
Bye
From BBC Learning English dot com